Born a slave,
he rose to become a
prominence abolitionist,
statesmen,
author and respected figure around
the world the most photographed
african-american of the 19th century.
He was also a recognizable figure even
as his very identity put him at risk for
much of his life.
Frederick Douglass story
is one of perseverance,
intellects,
and then an unending desire
for freedom and justice.
Frederick Douglas wasn't
born with that name,
noisy born on the day that he later
adopted as his best date of birth.
He was christened Frederick Augustus,
Washington Bailey.
The date he was born has
been lost to history.
Later in life.
You decided that February the 14th
would be the day on which he marked his
entrance into the wells.
He said,
I have no accurate knowledge of my age,
never having seen any authentic record
containing this is what he wrote in a
narrative of the life
of Frederick Douglass.
We do know though that Douglass was born
into slavery in Marilyn's likely the
son of a union between
his mother and that owner,
Douglass.
His mother was known for her intelligence
and is widely considered to be the
only slave who could read or write in
the area of Maryland's where she lived,
but was never really
got to know his mother.
It was common for infants born to slaves
to be separated from their mothers.
Soon after birth.
Taking care of children took up energy
and time that the younger women could use
to doing hard work on the
farm or the plantation.
Older women who weren't able to do such
physical neighbor could take care of
children and slave masters wouldn't
see a drop in productivity.
So Douglas,
like many slaves,
he grew up without his mother.
He was sent to live with his
grandmother that he bailey.
She was also the caretaker for
12 other children don't miss.
His mother was enslaved at
a different plantation here.
And you saw how a handful of times before
he was removed from his grandmother's
house at around age seven,
Douglas was separated from the family
that he knew he was taken from his
grandmother's home and was sent
to y plantation plantation.
He joined a thousand other slaves spread
across 20 farms owned bite master Lloyd
Douglas.
He didn't work in the fields.
He was still young and
so he didn't go out.
Instead,
you cared for the families,
cows and tended to the
houses garden and it's yacht.
It was while he was at this farm that
his mother died and then once again,
ductless was operated as a slave.
Douglass was forced to move and
serve the winds of his masters.
This time he was sent to Baltimore
to the family of Hugh old here.
Douglas followed in
his mother's footsteps.
He learns to read and write
is journey to literacy.
It started when Sophia,
old Hugh's wife again teaching
him the lessons of the alphabet.
It was unusual for a slave owner.
It's takes so much interest
in the education of a safe
and he did not like that.
His wife was doing site plus
all sorts that have slaves,
could read and write so they would be
more likely to want their freedom and more
likely to seek it out.
Douglas called all those
arguments against literacy.
His first decidedly anti slavery lecture.
Unfortunately,
Sophia came around to her husband's
way of thinking and Douglas is tutoring
sessions.
They came to an end,
but douglass believed that
once you learn to read,
you will be forever free,
and so he kept that name.
He taught himself to read,
grabbing any publication
that had words on it.
Newspapers and political pamphlets
joins books in his collection,
and Douglas began to learn
much more than how to read.
He was learning about the events of
the country and the rest of the world.
Among the publications he devoured
was the Colombian or race.
At this book was an 18th century
unfollow gig that was used as a literacy
teaching tool in classrooms for Douglas.
Though the book offered more than
just a lesson in reading and writing,
it gave him an insight
into ideas about freedom.
It's about human rights was he didn't
want to keep the power of literacy to
himself.
Though he started teaching other slaves
from nearby plantations to read during
Sunday school using the New Testament's,
dozens of slaves would
show up each week to learn.
Amazingly just went unnoticed
for nearly six months,
but when it was discovered that Douglas
was teaching fellow slaves to read and
write,
the slave owners were beside
themselves with anger.
One Sunday while Douglas was teaching
ve fuming owners bust into the makeshift
school,
they were intense that they're slaves
would not learn to read and write,
and they use violence to
get that point across.
They used stones and clubs to ends
that Sunday meeting and to end Dr says
teaching for the time.
Being.
Douglas was still a
teenager when this happened,
since he was already beginning
to make his mark on the world.
By the time Douglas had his teens,
he had also been moved from owner to
owner and plantation to plantation.
Several times in his late teens,
Douglas were sent to be
a slave for Edward Coby,
coby subjected to violence regularly
beating and whipping him and his book,
my bondage and my freedom.
Douglas entitles the chapter devoted to
his time on covese plantation as Colby,
the Negro breaker.
He rides if the beatings,
he sustained it covese hands.
I had not been in his possession
three whole days before.
You subjected me to almost brutal
chastisements onto his heavy blows.
Blood flowed freely and Wales will left
on my back as large as my middle finger.
The sores on my back from this flogging
continued for weeks for they were kept
open by the rough and coarse
cloth which I wore for shouting.
Eventually Douglass began to fight back.
He gave covey a taste of his own medicine,
and the man never tried to use
violence to control douglas game,
Douglas Near.
He couldn't continue life as a slave
beyond his own beliefs and desire for
freedom.
He had also met a woman who inspired
him to seek his own freedom,
and Maria was a free black
woman from Baltimore.
She not only inspire to douglass freedom,
but fell in love with him.
The two of them,
they later got married in 1836.
Douglas first attempted
to escape from slavery.
When his plan was discovered,
he was thrown in jail,
return to his own head.
Douglas remained a slave for two more
years before he able to make another
escape.
Attempts on September the third,
18,
38,
Douglas took the risk that he knew could
either start his life as a free man or
end it altogether.
I felt assured that if I failed in this
attempt to my case would be a hopeless
one.
It would seal my fate as a slave forever.
He later wrote he had obtained
papers showing him to be a free man,
a risky move in and of itself.
The neighbors belonged to a black sailor
and so douglas hats to act the part if
he wanted to be successful before leaving
his master's property in Baltimore.
Doesn't this costumed
himself in a red shirt,
black revamps and the sales hat while
he disguised himself with his clothes.
The plan still had one big floor.
Douglas wasn't a great physical match
for the description on the haters.
If an official stopped to closely consider
the measurements and the description
is journey to freedom,
it would be over.
Douglas boarded a train to Philadelphia,
and as expected,
he faced an inspection when he
was asked to show free papers.
Douglas handed over his sailors
identification and said,
I never carry my free
papers to see with me.
I have a paper with the American Eagle
on us that will carry me around the
world.
The answer and the papers
were enough for the conductor.
Douglas was free to stay on the
train and to continue his journey,
but he still had to make
it through slave states.
When he risked getting arrested
after an anxious journey,
Douglas stepped off the train in New
York and made his way to a group of
underground railroad activists.
He was in a free state,
but it was not a free man.
He was technically a fugitive,
so could still be arrested.
The danger was definitely
not over for him yet.
Nevertheless,
he was ecstatic to simply be
in one of these free states.
I've often been asked how I felt when
first I found myself on free soil.
There is scarcity.
Anything in my experience about which
I could not give a more satisfactory
answer and new world had opened upon me,
if life is more than breath ends,
the quick rounds of blood.
I lived more in one day and
then a year of my slave life.
It was a time of Jonah's excitement,
which words can,
but team the describe the underground
railroad activists provided them shelter
for a day and got words to his
beloved Anna that he was free.
She made her way up for Baltimore
and the two were married in New York.
Within days there a couple of world
further north to Massachusetts where life
was somewhat safer for a fugitive
slave that was still prejudice.
However,
in Douglas had to work hard to find even
the menial jobs where you could earn a
living.
While in new Bedford.
Douglas became a licensed preacher.
Auntie taught Sunday school
and served as church sexton.
They also became involved in
the abolitionist movements.
Douglas was inspired by abolitionist.
William Lloyd Garrison and
avidly read his newspaper,
the liberator.
The first time Douglas was asked to
speak as an abolitionist meeting.
He was frightened.
He had been unexpectedly asked to give a
speech at the Massachusetts antislavery
societies national convention.
Through his nervousness,
he gave an incredibly eloquent
and thoughtful speech,
unlikely white abolitionists who
gave most antislavery speeches.
Douglas could speak personally about
the pain and the brutality of slavery,
douglass skill,
public speaking.
It was quickly noticed and he talks more
and more at antislavery meetings and
soon he was a key part of
the abolitionist movements.
At meetings,
he would tell his story and
rouse crowds to the course.
In 18,
43,
he joins the American antislavery society
to toward the midwestern United States
and speak about the importance
of abolishing slavery.
They traveled for six months
spreading their message,
and in doing so often
putting themselves in danger.
This was two decades before the civil
war and slavery supporters wanted to make
themselves heard.
They turns violence on some occasions,
and Douglas had his hands broken during
one melly and Indiana Douglas didn't
just put his oratory skills to
work for the abolitionist movement.
Though he also wrote his autobiography,
telling the story of what it was
like to grow up and if a slave titled
Narrative,
the autobiography of Frederick Douglass,
the book was a huge success.
It had nine reprinting and was translated
so that it can be sold in Europe as
well.
The success of the book
that came with a cost,
though it attracted attention to Douglas
and he was still not a free man in the
eyes of the law.
Instead of going into
hiding in the United States,
though Douglas headed to Europe,
that he was safe from arrest and could
continue spreading his message and
telling his story.
During a two year tour
of England and Ireland,
he raised his profile both
back home and in Europe.
Crowds came to see him
speak and some twists.
His appeal that is European support it.
It's began raising money to
buy his freedom in America.
Douglas was also impressed with Europe.
He was treated like a person.
They're unlike.
He wasn't home instead of
a democratic governments.
I'm under a monarchical governments.
Instead of the bright
blue skies of America,
I'm covered with a softer
gray fog of the emerald aisle.
I breathe hands low.
The Chattel becomes a man I gave around
in vain for one who will question my
equal humanity,
claimed me as a slave
or offer me an insult.
I find myself regarded and treated at
every turn with the kindness and deference
paid to white people,
and I go to church.
I'm met by no upturns,
nose and scornful lip to tell
me we don't sell our niggas.
Yeah.
His supporters were successful in raising
the funds to buy douglass his freedom,
and he was able to return to America,
to his wife,
and to the course of freeing the
millions of slaves in the country.
He started publishing his own paper,
the North Star,
and also took up causes of freedom
beyond the abolitionist movements.
He spoke at the women's rights,
Seneca falls convention calling for
women to be granted the right to vote.
He also became active in cooling
for the desegregation of schools.
This is a full century before Brown and
board of education was decided by the
Supreme Court
because of his activism and this
perpetual presence in the abolitionist and
other movements,
Douglas was a highly recognized figure
in America when the civil war began
during the walk.
Douglas is a fierce advocate of allowing
African Americans to fight for the
union.
A war undertaken and brazenly carried
for the petrol enslavement of the colored
man calls logically and loudly for
the colored men to help suppress it.
Douglas even have the ear of Abraham
Lincoln and was able to speak to the
president about his views
on African American troops.
He used his publications and speeches
to call for the inclusion of African
Americans in the army for two years.
He kept working on this issue.
In 18,
63,
lincoln issued the emancipation
proclamation as African
Americans were free to
join the army.
Douglas and his family were ready
to have a son signed up to fight.
Under third became active in recruitments.
Douglas himself shifted his message from
encouraging the inclusion of African
Americans in the military to encouraging
African Americans to sign up to fight.
When time sample Carson and shall fall
upon our national tragedy than hillsides
and valleys,
johnny the red and with the bloods nor
Weisen with the bones of Kensington and
countrymen who have fallen in
the sanguinary ans wicked strife.
When grim massaged war has moved
his wrinkled front and our country,
you shall have regained its normal
condition as a leader of nations in the
occupation and blessings of peace and
history shall record the names of heroes
and martyrs who bravely answered the
call of patriotism and liberty against
traitors thieves and assassins it.
Nobody said this in the long
list of glory composed of men,
of all nations,
there appears the name of no colored man.
When the civil war ended,
slavery was outlawed.
Douglas did not step
away from public life.
He believed that was still much work
to be done in the fight for freedom.
He was appointed president
if the Freedman's bank,
which helped promote economic development
in the newly free African American
communities and also continued speaking
around the country and was active in
supporting ulysses s grant 18,
68 campaign for the presidency.
Then in 18,
72,
douglas was nominated
as Victoria woodhull,
his vice presidential running mate.
He didn't even know it had been nominated.
He didn't seek it out,
but the equal rights party,
but in one of the tickets nonetheless,
it wouldn't be as lost appearance
in a presidential race.
In 18,
88,
he became the first African American to
receive a vote for presidents as a major
party's convention.
His fame and his outspoken activism
still made him a target for sinister
activities.
However,
the same year he was nominated
as a vice presidential candidate.
His family's New York home
was targeted by an arsonist.
The family was safe,
but the far show that he
nor his African-american
Bretheran was still not safe
from violence even years
after the civil war and ended
Douglas spent the last two decades of
his life in Washington dc where he served
as a United States marshal.
We have an appointment
from President Hayes.
He and Anna lived in a
home called Cedar Hill.
And,
uh,
his first love and his inspiration for
his escape from slavery died in 18.
80 two.
Douglas remarried this time
to a much younger white women.
It's children were upset and
this was his new wife's family.
During the 18 eighties,
he continued traveling both
the country and the world,
giving speeches on a
number of political issues.
He also kept writing and issued a new
edition of his autobiography and 80 slash
81.
The life and times of Frederick
Douglass was his third book.
It also published my bondage
and my freedom in 1855.
The political appointments kept coming to.
He said often diplomatic positions as
recorder of deeds for DC into commission
now,
roughly welds Colombian exposition.
Douglas was speaking and crusading for
rice right until the end of his life in
1995,
he gave a speech at the national
convention of Women in DC.
He was incredibly well received,
but it was the last
speech he would ever give.
Shortly after the speech,
he had a heart attack and passed away.
He was 77 years old.
Thousands paid their respects to this
funeral in DC and Dr [inaudible] body was
then returned to Rochester,
New York,
where he was buried next to Anna Frederick
Douglass risked his life for freedom.
Not so many when he escaped from slavery,
but every time he put himself
out there as a public figure,
advocating for an end to slavery,
the right to vote and
civil rights for all.
We're going to leave you today with some
of his own powerful words where justice
is denied,
where poverty is enforced,
where ignorance prevails ends,
where any one class is made to feel that
society is an organized conspiracy to
oppress rob and degrade them.
Neither persons nor property will be safe.
So I really hope you enjoyed
that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now,
one is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos
every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and
subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a
notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to
the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday
won't put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch
something else right now,
suffering the archive over
there on the race and as always,
thank you for it.